einstein was reputed to have said that
if bees died out
then mankind would only have four years
left to live
our project is called bison biodiversity
it's part of a trans-european project
involving seven countries
its aim is to preserve bees as
pollinating insects as part of
biodiversity
eighty percent of the program is funded
by europe that's the leader project
the bees are up against a lot really
because
climate change may have a lot to do with
it we're not sure but in a very cold
winter
a lot of bees died we also have
monoculture
we have three actions in our action plan
the first action is land management
where we plant wildflowers
the second action
is education
going into schools and getting children
enthusiastic about bees
and the third action
is keeping bees ourselves
as far as land management is concerned
we haven't just planted wild flowers
in the wild but we've actually given out
packets of seeds and encouraged people
to plant in back gardens and it's been
fantastic the amount of different
varieties
biodiversity is a responsibility of
everybody we can talk to local
government and talk to our farmers
and then go into europe
and between us we can form this absolute
synergy of
encouragement and enthusiasm
so that
the ecology becomes better and not worse
you